Salut sa fait quelques temps que je n'ai pas parlé de livres sur cette chaîne alors attention ne fuyez pas
parce que ce livre là c'est juste de la bombe. Aujourd'hui on va parler un petit peu du contenu du livre d'Olivier Roland le
best-seller qui s'appelle "tout le monde n'a pas eu la chance de rater ses études " et sans trop vous teeser derrière ce titre un
peu aguicheur se cache réellement un pur contenu
olivier Rolland l'auteur je crois que je l'ai rencontré au mois de mai on a dû se rencontrer pour la première fois au mois
de mai de cette année et en déjeunant ensemble on s'est déjà rendu vite compte qu'on avait beaucoup de points communs par exemple lui et moi
on a arrêté les études classiques assez tôt pour
s'autoformer et l'un comme l'autre et sûrement vous on a toujours été à la recherche de hack pour s'optimiser
et sans le connaître à l'époque quand il a sorti son livre ya quelques années je m'étais jeté dessus
c'est la première fois que je vois un livre dans ce domaine qui contient autant de références scientifiques
il ya plus de 400 sources scientifiques à l'intérieur ce qui fait forcément que tous les bas de pages sont annotés d'ailleurs mais c'est surtout ce
qui fait que le contenu de ce livre est très intéressant en fait il a fait un travail de regroupement
de tout ce qu'il a appris ou de techniques et lui qui l'a qu'il a créé alors pour améliorer son Q.I pour améliorer sa concentration
en fait pour s'améliorer tout court puisque le but de ce livre c'est que tu puisses
cartonner dans n'importe quel domaine après l'idée principale c'est d'hacker ton éducation
pour apprendre efficacement et du coup en faisant ce travail de recherche de filtres en
compilant tout ça dedans mais en le mettant toujours en corrélation avec des études scientifiques
hé bé ça devient une mine d'or en fait j'utilise un petit peu le mot bible parce que je trouve que
je trouve que c'est le cas dans cette vidéo je veux revenir rapidement sur
5 points du livre qui m'avait particulièrement intéressé sur l'ensemble des points pour devenir ce qu'Olivier Rolland appelle un rebelle intelligent premier point
la loi de pareto à l'intérieur il ya tout un chapitre dédié à la loi de pareto qu'est la loi du 80 20
en clair Vilfredo Pareto avait constaté un jour que
80% des richesses était détenu par 20% de la population et de la même manière 20%
des pays se partagent
80% des ressources mondiales ce qui est intéressant là dedans c'est que si on fait le parallèle sur d'autres choses par exemple sur les techniques
d'apprentissage ça peut voir à dire que sur toutes les méthodes qu'on utilise seulement 20 % d'entre elles
génèrent 80 % du contenu qu'on apprend et on peut résumer ça par cette phrase
80% des effets sont produits par 20 % des causes et je suis assez d'accord avec ça c'est à dire que une fois pour le
coup qu'on a identifié
quels étaient les 20% de cause on va pouvoir éliminer ce qui sert à rien ou ce qui sert trop peu pour
optimiser ses 20% là et soit être encore plus productif dans ce qu'on essaie de faire ou dans ce qu'on essaie d'apprendre ou soit encore
mieux
générer du temps libre on se détendent ou pour faire autre chose d'autres projets peu importe dans le livre on retrouve aussi énormément de choses
entre l'intelligence brute et
l'intelligence sociale
c'est à dire qu'il ne remet pas en cause le fait d'apprendre c'est bien d'apprendre et au contraire en fait d'apprendre toute sa vie mais dans l'idéal
d'apprendre de manière pratique par exemple si on essayait d'apprendre une nouvelle langue lui
applique la loi du 80 20 c'est à dire qu'il va lister quelle est la population mondiale parlant cette langue
quelles sont les méthodes d'apprentissage et de là il va en extraire quel est le plus rentable et le plus efficace
et quelle est la langue la plus parlée pour faire son tableau des 80 20 et savoir réellement quelle langue et avec quelles méthodes
il est rentable d'apprendre. L'intelligence brute c'est le fait d'avoir des connaissances dans un domaine
comme on apprend au cours des choses comme ça en bloc sans avoir toujours de buts derrière
l'intelligence sociale est un petit peu différente alors elle vient d'une connaissance technique, théorique
parfois
mais elle a quasiment toujours un but par exemple moi dans le tournage des vidéos dans l'écriture d'un montage j'ai appris au fur et à mesure
et au fur et à mesure de mes besoins j'ai pas cherché à tout savoir d'un coup
j'ai essayé à chaque fois de faire des petits pas en fonction de mes besoins et en fait l'intelligence sociale c'est surtout la capacité
d'analyser et de réagir c'est d'ailleurs qu'on peut être premier de la classe bardé de mentions sur un diplôme en
particulier et ne pas s'en sortir après dans le monde de l'entreprise ou de
l'entrepreneuriat si ont choisi cette voie là le livre il est assez consacré d'ailleurs simplement parce qu'on n'aura pas eu les tips pour réfléchir pour
analyser pour s'adapter et aussi pour communiquer socialement et pour le coup le système scolaire tue un peu cette créativité qui est
nécessaire en fait à la réflexion et à l'adaptation pour
pour aujourd'hui et pour plus tard et c'est pour ça qu'en troisième point j'aimerais revenir sur tous les passages sur l'auto éducation qui est je pense
l'un des des trucs qui m'a le plus plu à l'époque dans ce bouquin : comment apprendre vite tout le temps
efficacement et avec plaisir et là c'est génial parce que ça va de techniques de mémorisation
de comment maîtriser sa courbe d'oubli à des choses comme hacker et votre corps pour tripler votre énergie c'est hyper malin d'aborder ce genre de
sujet dans le livre parce que si tu arrives à
optimiser en fait ton énergie est ton rapport à ton corps ben forcément ton esprit sera encore plus efficace
ça il vous le décline en cinq points dans le livre votre mémoire à long terme votre mémoire de travail votre capacité de concentration
la volonté et la motivation qui sont à peu près les valeurs que je prône sur cette chaîne depuis maintenant un an et demi avec
toujours ce petit rappel du 80 20
la bonne nouvelle est que pour chacune de ces compétences fondamentales il existe des outils et des méthodes 80 20 pour augmenter grandement vos capacités. Commençons
par le commencement
bla bla bla et justement en 4e point je veux revenir sur quelque chose que je connaissais pas que j'ai pu expérimenter cas c'est perturbant mais très
efficace le titre s'appelle comment un objet banal va renforcer votre volonté votre productivité là je me suis dit un objet peut renforcer notre productivité
je suis pas sûr en fait tout ça vient d'une étude et encore une fois tout est sourcé et dans le livre c'est l'étude du
miroir ils ont invité un groupe d'enfants
à halloween dans une pièce pour en faire cette recherche là et il y avait un adulte et plein de bonbons et l'adulte dit je
je pars quelques secondes surtout ne mangez pas de bonbons et il revient quelques minutes après il y a eu deux groupes différents un groupe où
il y avait un
miroir à côté des bonbons se dire que s'ils en prenaient ils se voyaient faire et un groupe où il n'y avait pas de miroir
et bien le groupe où il n'y avait pas de miroir 34 % des enfants
on désobéit et mangé des bonbons et le groupe où il y avait un miroir 9 % seulement ont désobéi et mangé des bonbons
l'expérience a été reproduite dans des bureaux où il y a un miroir
sur la zone de travail à côté de l'ordinateur ou à côté du livre si des gens doivent réviser etc et la
productivité augmenter jusqu'à 25
30% parce qu'à ce moment là on se juge soit même si on arrête on se voit arrêter et c'est très perturbant et on a
tendance à s'y remettre dans les techniques il aborde pour la volonté il aborde aussi des points qui étaient pas qu'ils ne seraient pas moi
spontanément venus à l'esprit comme par exemple le démon blanc
à savoir le sucre comment gérer sa glycémie quels sont les effets bénéfiques et
négatifs et comment en fait gérer notre consommation de sucre
pour
optimiser sa volonté de c'est hyper intéressant et en dernier point je vais vous parler de quelque chose que j'avais découvert dans le livre que
vous m'avez vu faire d'une manière ou d'une autre plusieurs fois sur la chaîne quand j'ai
écrit mon livre moi aussi ou ce genre de choses c'est le test des 30 jours
en fait il propose un test de 30 jours seulement 30 jours pour voir si quelque chose est
bénéfique ou pas pour vous dans votre vie déjà mentalement c'est intéressant parce que vous avez pas vous dire
je veux faire ça toute ma vie
donnez une période donnée de 30 jours pour tester quelque chose vous vous dites c'est bon c'est un test ça engage à rien par exemple
vous pouvez vous dire moi durant
30 jours je vais essayer de ne pas regarder la télé j'ai juste regarder les replays de tel tel et tel émission qui me
plaisent particulièrement
mais durant 30 jours je regarde plus la télé et au bout des 30 jours je fais le bilan
pour voir ce que ça a donné dans ma vie de positif ou négatif
et je
déciderai de continuer ou pas ou ça peut agir en 30 jours chaque jour je me débarrasser d'un objet dont je me sers plus et
pourquoi pas essayer de le vendre plutôt que de le jeter tout est possible avec la méthode des 30 joueurs vous voyez c'est vraiment un
point de départ j'ai pas vous dire en fait tout tout tout ce qui dit dans le livre
mais je pense que vous
percevez la puissance de sa là je viens juste d'aborder avec vous cinq points de la première moitié du livre mais vraiment je reviens là dessus c'est
vraiment quelque chose d'ultra complet la seconde partie du livre est plus axée sur la liberté et
l'entrepreneuriat et le thème de l'ensemble du livre c'est comment devenir un rebelle intelligent comme je vous le disais au début de la vidéo ça
fait à peu près six mois maintenant que je connais
Olivier qu'on se connaît bien mais c'est pas pour ça que je parle du livre je parle du livre qu'est-ce qu'il est bien et c'est
parce que le livre était bien que j'ai voulu rencontrer Olivier et si vous avez l'occasion le rencontrer un jour il est très accessible
et c'est assez passionnant de parler avec lui quand j'ai décidé de faire cette vidéo forcément je l'ai prévenu je lui ai demandé est-ce que tu
veux que je renvoie
les gens sur ton youtube, ton facebook ce genre de choses si jamais ils veulent en savoir plus sur toi et il
m'a proposé en fait c'est très sympa de sa part de vous fournir un extrait du livre donc dans la description
également sûrement dans une fiche autour de moi ou je sais pas trop où je vais vous mettre un lien qui vous permet d'avoir un
extrait du livre ans qu'Olivier a mit exprès en place pour nous donc pour vous et
pour ça merci à lui n'hésitez pas à aller voir parce que moins cher que gratuit
je vois pas trop ce que ça pourrait être donc le voilà allez voir ça allez checker ça j'espère que ça vous aura plus ça faisait
bien 4/5 mois que j'avais pas parlé d'un livre sur la chaîne et quel livre c'était
vraiment cool de pouvoir aborder celui ci avec vous si vous avez des titres donc vous aimeriez que je parle aussi dites le moi dans
les commentaires et s'il y a des titres qui m'intéressent et que j'ai pas lu je me fera plaisir également de les lire
n'oubliez pas de liker la vidéo si elle vous a plu et vous abonner comme d'habitude tout ça
encore une fois merci à olivier Rolland de nous avoir fourni cet extrait n'hésitez pas à le télécharger et à très bientôt ciao
alors si c'est pas encore fait tu peux aussi t'abonner à la chaîne
simplement en cliquant sur le petit rond que tu vois voilà juste ici c'est ce petit rond là ça marche depuis la tablette le téléphone
c'est extrêmement pratique il n'y a plus de raison d'attendre
allez-y abonnez vous c'est cool